this morning president biden will speak
with chinese president xi jinping about
the war now russia has asked china for
military aid but the u.s has warned
beijing there will be tough consequences
if it says yes nancy cordes is at the
white house with more on that story i
think we're in a genuine struggle
between autocracies and democracies this
will be president biden's first call
with chinese president xi jinping since
november well before the invasion
mr biden argued freedom itself is at
stake remind me that i told him he
remembers every damn thing i've said
unfortunately
but all kidding aside
we talked about the idea he he does not
believe about democracies can be
sustained in the 21st century china is
one of the few countries that have not
condemned putin's actions instead
officials there have described their
relationship with russia as rock solid
[Applause]
when the u.n voted overwhelmingly to
demand russia withdraw its troops china
abstained china is really in somewhat of
a predicament because uh all the images
of the destruction the tragedy within
the ukraine is being broadcast
and being seen by the chinese people and
has much to gain economically with its
ties to russia russia has reportedly
asked china for military aid that
includes everything from surface-to-air
missiles to drones to mres
food rations for stalled troops a
request both russia and china deny
today's call comes just two days after
president biden described russian
president vladimir putin the first time
as a war criminal personally
i agree secretary of state anthony
blinken warned yesterday that the
crippling sanctions placed on russia
could easily expand to its neighbor too
the china will bear responsibility for
any actions it takes to support russia's
aggression and we will not hesitate to
impose costs
with russia's economy in free fall
china's choices over the next couple of
weeks could be pivotal if china does not
give russia the military assistance it's
seeking russia's financial ability to
wage this war withers that much quicker
and that's why there's so much riding
vlad on this call today between
presidents biden and she
looking forward to the readout after
that nancy quarters for us at the white
house nancy thank you very much